imagine this your six-month-old telling
you that they're thirsty or want their
favorite toy without words well it turns
out there's a great way for them to do
that with sign language a Las Vegas
daycare center shows our Candace Charles
how it works and how it helps child
development
folks I have a question for you do you
know what this means or this well it's
two of many gestures children as young
as six months have learned and are using
at The Learning Experience daycare
center in Rhodes ranch take a look
these toddlers have a lot to say but
they can show you better than they can
tell you with the baby sign language
and they just grasp it because it is
things they use every day like milk more
and water hungry all things and fillings
we can appreciate but don't necessarily
know how to sign innately or maybe we do
kids especially little ones are sponges
they pick up everything it's called
observational learning some studies say
babies can pick up signing quicker than
adults but these good signs come with
practice and even more thank you maybe a
little bit more thank you I know you
want to blow kisses repetition
learning ASL results in two key benefits
for babies it's the easiest way for them
to tell us what they need it helps our
cognitive and social emotional
development because they can Bond more
but find out more about the learning
experience acre Center in Rhodes ranch
go to our website 8newsnow.com by the
way this means please and this means
you're welcome in The Newsroom Kansas
Charles 8 News Now